an outpouring of love support and
financial aid from Hollywood to Houston
as the aftermath of Hurricane Harvey
continues to wreak havoc Beyonce Sandra
Bullock they're just a fraction of the
big names opening up their hearts and
their wallets right now this is Oscar
winner Jamie Foxx drops huge plans for
an all-star relief effort just wanna let
everybody in Texas know that we got you
and also September 12th we have a
telethon that we're doing where we can
raise as much money as we can for
everybody down there Texas native Jamie
Foxx teased an upcoming relief telethon
it's reportedly being put together by
the same organizers behind Ariana
Grande's Manchester benefit no word if
Beyonce will perform but her Texas
pastor Rudy Rasmus told me the singer
has already made a significant donation
what does it mean to have someone like
Beyonce to turn to in a time of need and
knowing that she is ready to step up she
is one of the most generous people that
I know and just cial in that big
platform of hers to help the needy any
day of the week and I love her for it
actress Sandra Bullock is stepping up
donating a staggering 1 million dollars
to relief efforts and yesterday in Los
Angeles Reese Witherspoon showed her
support proudly wearing this Texas pride
pin at the premiere of her new movie
home again she told Cameron there's one
item survivors urgently need diapers is
something that is not provided by a lot
of relief organizations so anyway could
send diapers it's incredible and last
night on America's Got Talent an
inspiring moment of hope the moment that
got me was sketchy
and then knowing that she's from Houston
[Applause]
this contestant who survived a tragic
plane crash sang by the grace of God
[Music]
I want people to know that no matter how
much life tries to push you down and
keep you down you can not only get back
on your feet but you can thrive
[Applause]